Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
On a tous entendu qu’on sauvera
ensemble la planète
en arrêtant de manger de la viande,
que les vaches qui pètent sont
responsables du dérèglement climatique,
que pour faire un kilo de steak,
il faut 15 000 litres d’eau.
Vous imaginez bien que les choses
sont bien plus compliquées que ça,
que c’est bien moins manichéen que ça.
Je suis Félix Noblia,
paysan au Pays basque,
un peu influenceur,
un peu lobbyiste écolo bénévole.
J’ai repris une ferme il y a 14 ans.
Une ferme où je suis passé
d’un modèle très traditionnel
à un modèle qu’on pourrait [qualifier]
d’agriculture régénérative,
d’agro-écologie.
Je vais vous expliquer ce que c’est.
Est-ce que vous savez ce qu’est
le dérèglement climatique, déjà ?
Le dérèglement climatique,
ce sont des gaz,
du CO2, du méthane, du protoxyde d’azote
qui vont dans l’atmosphère
et qui participent
à un réchauffement planétaire.
Ce réchauffement crée des grosses
conséquences sur l’ensemble des activités.
Vous connaissez tout ça,
vous en avez déjà entendu parler.
C’est comme si on nous disait
que se déplacer,
ça pose des problèmes
pour le dérèglement climatique
et qu’on va mettre dans le même sac
l’aviation d’affaires et la marche à pied.
Vous savez bien que ce n’est pas pareil ;
dans l’élevage, c’est la même chose.
Il y a des modèles d’élevage
qui vont améliorer la planète
et d’autres qui vont l’abîmer.
Par exemple, on va nous dire :
« Les animaux, ça va [consommer]
de la nourriture qui pourrait être
consommée par les humains. »
Mais en fait, 86% de la nourriture
utilisée par les animaux
sont des choses non valorisables
pour l’humain - ça fait 14 % de trop.
Ce que je vais vous raconter là,
c’est, dans les graines,
comment ça se passe aujourd’hui ?
Par exemple, une graine de soja.
Une graine de soja, aujourd’hui,
si vous la passez dans un estomac animal,
elle vaut 300 euros la tonne.
Si vous la passez
dans l’industrie agro-alimentaire,
elle vaut 30 000 euros la tonne.
Pourquoi ? Je vais vous raconter ça.
C’est que les industriels -
Ça fait 100 fois plus cher.
Les industriels ont intérêt à ce que
le soja ne passe pas dans les animaux.
Ça, c’est quelque chose qu’il faut
que les consommateurs comprennent.
34 % des aliments achetés
sont des aliments
ultra-transformés aujourd’hui.
Et ces aliments ultra-transformés,
quelles conséquences ont-ils
sur votre santé ?
Posez-vous cette question-là.
Le budget que vous mettez
dans l’alimentation,
en 50 ans, il est passé de 30 %
à 11 % - trois fois moins.
Qu’est-ce que vous voulez ?
Est-ce que vous voulez dépenser
des sous dans des produits alimentaires,
ou est-ce que vous voulez investir
dans votre santé ?
Ça, c'est quelque chose de déterminant.
Maintenant, je vais vous raconter
comment ça se passe sur ma ferme.
En fait, sur ma ferme,
il y a plusieurs ateliers :
un atelier de maraîchage,
un atelier de grande culture,
un atelier avec des porcs
et un autre avec des bovins.
En fait, tout est lié.
Les cochons, par exemple,
qu’est-ce que ça doit bouffer ?
Un cochon, c’est sur une ferme
pour recycler.
Ça va manger des déchets de triage.
On va trier les céréales :
il y en a qui sont consommables par
l’humain, d’autres qu’on va devoir jeter.
Au lieu de les jeter,
on les donne aux cochons.
Ça va manger des légumes abîmés,
des céréales non consommables
pour l’homme.
Il y a des normes à vérifier
sur les mycotoxines, sur plein de choses,
mais en gros, le cochon, il recycle.
Et une vache, qu’est-ce que ça mange ?
Une vache,
un herbivore,
est-ce que ça bouffe des graines
ou est-ce que ça bouffe de l’herbe ?
Ça, c'est déterminant aussi.
Je vous raconte tout ça
parce que les bovins auront -
et ça, c’est la phrase que je veux
que vous reteniez -
l’impact environnemental
du mode de vie
que l’on aura choisi pour eux.
Je vous la refais :
ils auront l’impact environnemental
du mode de vie qu’on aura choisi pour eux.
Et ça, c’est hyper important.
Comment les bovins vivent sur ma ferme ?
Au lieu d’avoir, comme vous le voyez là,
une pâture avec une grande parcelle
où il y a plein de bestioles,
et des vaches qui mangent
le moindre brin d’herbe,
vous avez toutes ces vaches qui sont
concentrées sur une toute petite parcelle.
On va découper cette parcelle
en plusieurs petites parcelles
et elles vont tourner tous les jours.
Elles vont avoir tout le temps
de l’herbe fraîche à manger.
Ça laissera le temps
à la prairie de se régénérer,
à l’herbe de repousser.
Ce mode de gestion des animaux,
il est déterminant pour toutes les
conséquences que je vais expliquer.
Ça génère des impacts environnementaux
positifs sur plein de choses.
On peut améliorer de manière
très importante le système.
Si on commence à rajouter des arbres
entre ces parcelles,
on va avoir le même impact
environnemental qu’une forêt,
mais avec de la production alimentaire.
Ça commence à être intéressant.
Par exemple, le protoxyde d’azote.
Je l’ai cité tout à l’heure
dans les gaz réchauffants.
Il est lié à l’utilisation d’engrais.
Dans un système comme le mien,
zéro engrais.
Il n’y a pas d’engrais.
Le système se régénère tout seul,
avec les excréments des animaux.
Ces systèmes favorisent aussi de
manière très importante la biodiversité,
ça favorise de manière très
importante la santé de l’animal.
Tout ça, c’est extrêmement intéressant :
dans des systèmes vertueux, quand on va
dans un sens, tout va dans le même sens.
Le système-là est intéressant
parce qu’il est transposable partout
et c’est ça qui réglera
le problème du dérèglement climatique.
Il faut arriver à produire
un maximum de biomasse partout -
la biomasse, c’est la végétation.
Il faut un maximum de végétation partout.
Plus on va avoir de végétation,
plus elle va transpirer.
Plus elle va transpirer,
plus ça va faire de la vapeur d’eau,
plus ça va faire des nuages.
Plus vous allez avoir de la végétation,
plus vous allez avoir le sol à l’ombre.
À l’ombre, vous sentez
que la température est plus fraîche.
Là, c’est pareil,
mais si vous avez ça sous un arbre,
ce n’est pas du tout la même chose
sur une centaine de milliers d’hectares.
Ou sur un million.
Si vous voulez transposer ça
à l’échelle globale,
vous pouvez baisser la température
de 4, 5, 6 degrés -
les points chauds des villes,
c’est autre chose -
mais on peut la baisser.
Si vous baissez la température
sur un gros territoire,
votre masse d’eau qui arrive
sous forme de nuage, elle tombe, il pleut.
Comme la forêt amazonienne :
la végétation appelle la pluie.
C’est transposable
dans nos systèmes de culture.
Et c’est passionnant.
Ensuite, plus vous avez de végétation,
plus vous avez de racines,
des racines qui vont chercher
des éléments minéraux dans le sol,
qui vont faire des symbioses
avec les champignons du sol.
Ces champignons du sol vont
aller chercher des minéraux
et ils vont les mettre à disposition de la
plante qui va être mieux équilibrée.
Et ceux qui vont manger la plante,
que ce soit des animaux ou nous,
ça les rend en meilleure santé.
Plus vous allez avoir de biomasse -
c’est là qu’on atteint le cœur du sujet,
la partie intéressante -
plus vous allez avoir de photosynthèse :
le soleil tape sur la meilleure machine
que personne ait jamais inventée -
elle existait avant nous :
une plante.
Il tape sur la feuille
qui transforme le CO2 en sucre.
Ce sucre, il descend dans la plante,
il va dans la racine,
il va dans le champignon du sol,
le mycorhize,
et le mycorhize le transforme dans une
forme qui s’appelle une glycoprotéine.
Cette glycoprotéine, c’est du stockage
de carbone de manière très durable,
c’est la colle du sol.
En fait, le sol est capable
de séquestrer du carbone,
capable d’absorber plus
de carbone qu’il n’en émet.
Plus vous aurez de végétation,
plus vous aurez de biomasse,
plus vous allez stocker de carbone.
Donc il faut viser des systèmes agricoles
qui vont développer la biomasse,
qui vont faire un maximum de biomasse.
Et donc, sur ma ferme aujourd’hui,
on estime avec les valeurs françaises
qu’on est à peu près à 177 tonnes
de carbone stockées par an.
177 tonnes de carbone stockées par an,
ça commence à être intéressant,
on est plus d’une tonne par hectare.
Mais maintenant,
je vais prendre un peu de hauteur.
Le carbone en France,
avec les systèmes de mesure,
il est mesuré entre 15
et 20 cm dans le sol.
Sauf qu'une racine, ça descend
bien plus profond.
On va trouver des racines qui vont
à quinze mètres de profondeur.
Ça peut aller vraiment très profond.
Qu’est-ce que je veux vous dire ?
C’est que si on prend vraiment
la globalité du potentiel des plantes -
je ne parle pas de géo-ingénierie,
je suis en train de vous
parler de la nature -
si on prend le potentiel des plantes
et qu’on commence à prendre
en compte 80 cm à peu près
et qu’on commence à prendre en compte
les meilleurs systèmes de pâturage,
on est capable d’aller
jusqu’à des niveaux de séquestration
qui montent jusqu’à 40 tonnes par hectare.
Je ne sais pas si vous imaginez
ce que c’est,
mais pour le représenter,
en gros, les émissions françaises
de gaz à effet de serre, c’est 9 tonnes,
si on devait les ramener à l’hectare.
Donc les systèmes agricoles
pourraient stocker trois fois
ce qu’on émet en termes
de gaz à effet de serre.
Mais on n’arrivera pas à le transposer
partout, ça mettra du temps, etc.
Je vous raconte ça
parce que, pour moi,
c’est important que vous compreniez
que l’impact environnemental
des bovins ou de la viande,
il est celui que l’on choisit
autant en termes de consommation
qu’en termes de modèle agricole.
On peut aller très loin dans ces systèmes.
Des trucs qui pourraient être un problème,
on en fait une solution.
Une chose dont je n’ai pas parlé,
sur laquelle je voudrais insister,
c’est l’aspect santé.
Des animaux herbivores
qui mangent de l’herbe,
ça fait de la viande riche
en antioxydants, riche en oméga 3,
et du lait riche en oméga 3.
Ça fait de la viande et du lait
qui sont anti-inflammatoires,
alors que si vous avez
des herbivores qui bouffent des graines
et qui n’ont pas ces antioxydants,
ça fait de la viande et du lait
qui sont inflammatoires.
En termes de santé,
quand on a des viandes ou du lait
qui sont faits correctement,
ça lutte contre l’ensemble
des maladies chroniques.
Et le COVID,
c’est une maladie qui est liée
à notre faiblesse immunitaire
et à la mauvaise alimentation.
Et c’est pour ça que vraiment,
je voudrais qu’on insiste sur le fait que,
si on mange bien, si on se nourrit bien et
si on choisit la bonne politique agricole,
on voit que le dérèglement climatique,
ce n’est plus un problème sociétal,
mais c’est vraiment un problème
de choix de politique agricole.
Et la solution, elle existe et on l’a.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)